Fran Fraschilla ESPN Westwood one
college basketball analyst and doing
some studio work for the tournament Fran
good morning thanks for joining us let
me start with this you're friends with
Tom Izzo did he go above and beyond the
call of duty last night man he got close
he really got close to and I was
cringing when I was watching the studio
now I have to tell you a you and I of
the same era essentially the same heroes
too by the way and I I think when you go
play for Tom Izzo you understand that
he's going to get everything out of you
that he's going to put his arm around
you and love you and oh by the way you
know when you're when you show up at an
NBA training camp and you're gonna be
fighting for the 12th spot on that team
and it's you and some guy from a school
in the pac-10 you've got a huge
advantage because you've been coached
hard in college so I was construing for
a young man the rest of the game and I
did say on the air Dan I thought after
Tom knew his temper that the team was
spooked you saw it on him everybody turn
calm down they did not play well really
from the rest of the game but thankfully
that young man Aaron came up in some big
plays I personally understand Tom I know
he was trying to do I think that he came
very close on the other hand man this is
sad this is how sometimes get the most
out of a kid ya know which pushes
buttons to push and you're gone to
Michigan State moment that's part of the
deal best team you saw yesterday was who
well the best performance it wasn't just
the performance of the tournament by
John Moran I thought of Murray State as
a 12 seed I mean they hammered Marquette
so were they the best team yesterday I'm
not sure but man that was breathtaking
to watch it really was a kid like that
he reminds me of probably playing with
Drew Brees you know if you pull out
yarns and and and and run an out pattern
you know the ball is going to be there
on time
our target this kids not only an
outstanding athlete but some of the
passes he threw yesterday were
absolutely breathtaking
could you make a case to take him number
one overall in today's NBS yes now let
me let me tell you what I've thought all
along
I saw his eye on last August when I
bought my little ESPN Plus package and
there were a lot of trips to Canada and
I said to myself and there's nobody like
this kid he's been up on taking the
grass after watching John Moran I still
think Zions going number one but you
really and I think Zions going to be a
terrific Pro by the way and make a
billion dollars in the you know in the
meantime but if you are the Phoenix Suns
and you need a point guard because you
have this incredible gift in Devin
Booker and you got DeAndre eight ok
who's getting better about a month
you're probably still gonna take Zion
but you really have to take a hard look
at this kid
we may be watching a situation where
like Kevin Durant went number two and
Jordan went number three we really could
be watching the dawning of an age where
we've kid I got a kid from a small
school in Western Kentucky who who could
end up being I think he's gonna be as
good in the NBA as we saw yesterday
because the way the rules are and the
type of talent you play with it's only
gonna magnify the things he already does
great he reminded me a little bit he he
reminds me a little bit of Russell
Westbrook that he goes straight at you
he's not afraid he'll dunk on you I
think he's a scorer
I don't know if he's a great shooter now
judging from what I've seen so far can
you see any similarities there and you
think he'll develop into a a very good
shooter or is he going to be a scorer
like Westbrook is well I think I've seen
games this year where he's you know he's
banged two or three threes in a row I
think in again if he gets the Westbrook
level I think anybody drafts and would
be ecstatic I actually think it's a much
better passer at the same stage yeah and
it's not not to take anything away from
Russell's triple doubles by the way
night and night out but what the other
thing you and I both know is when you
don't have to go to
psychology 201 in American history
you know 101 and you river the gym as a
professional player and given the fact
that it looks like he's made a huge jump
from his freshman year to a sophomore
year and that apparently he loves to
play and live in the gym I can't see
that he won't become at least an average
to an above-average shooter if you know
obviously it's not a JJ reddick I don't
see that in the cards but I think he's
gonna shoot well enough to keep deep
teams honest but the way the rules are
DEA you can't hand check anybody so he
is flying to the basket in my opinion
he's Fran Fraschilla ESPN Westwood one
college basketball analyst how if you're
Coach K what do you say to Xion
Williamson so he doesn't try to do too
much I don't think I think when you I
think fortunately because they have a 16
you know vs. 1 situation today I think
this is the ideal at the time for Zion
and those other freshmen to get their
feet wet I don't think he says very much
except just enjoy the moment let's do
what we've done all year you know the
old standard coaching cliche let's start
the one game winning streak and I I
don't sense that you have to do much
with this kid I mean he gets himself
ready to play you know he plays what a
joy that I think has made him such a you
know a household name already I think
you may have to want to come calm those
all those freshmen down a little bit but
I think the beauty of the tournament is
except for last year in the UMB
situation with Virginia I think they're
going to be able to ease in this
tournament and get their feet wet
without too much trouble I know that
we've talked about the draft with Zion
and John Moran but you're really
educated in those European players is
there a top five talent is there a Lucca
done check in this draft coming up I
wish I could tell you there were Dan but
there's not there really isn't
there'll be a few get a few kids drafted
once again middle of the late first
round but Halley's Comet passed over
last year and you know we may not see
one for another you know five to seven
or eight years and
a the kid just what'd he do he just
turned 20 yeah he turned 20 in February
what he's doing is actually surprising I
thought he would be a starter over his
career a high-level starter I saw a
little Ginobili in him I saw a little
Gordon Hayward good for him you know he
had a lot of doubters coming in because
because of where he comes from but what
we've seen in basketball in my lifetime
is the basketball globe has shrunk
incredibly so now the kid from Sylvania
is just as good as the kid from LA or
Chicago but if we redrafted who goes
number one overall you know it's a tough
call because I really like to wait
DeAndre Aidan's coming coming on I think
I think he's going to be an outstanding
NBA player but if you make me pick given
the early success I'm gonna take
knowledge but I'm not gonna lie now I
don't want you to think I'm an
international file now and all I you
know that I have a turkey Avista poster
in my office because I don't but I do
think that I did have DeAndre first Luca
second last and you know you can flip a
coin right now but Dodge is just
definitely off to a great start
I give me the upset special today or
tonight stuff in my in my behind er uh
I'll give you one let me see I don't
give me some teams and I'll throw knives
because I'm not getting ready to walk
over to the studio
Paulie throw out North Carolina I'll
tell you a great games Washington I do
the team that I think is gonna win
tonight and then maybe win another game
and that is well maybe not I don't think
number one seed but watch out for Utah
State I really like this team they've
gotta try and by the way they have a
terrific young big guy from Portugal a
fun game for people to watch tonight is
going to be UCF and VCU now they see you
starting point guard has been banged up
if County Dawkins wins tonight we assume
that Dirk will win
you have a matchup not only of the
arguably the greatest coach you know
maybe in sports history or certainly in
college basketball history versus the
guy that he claims was the reason who
became Duke and that is Johnny Dawkins
arguably in Jay Bilas is mine Tommy a
makers mind at Coach K's mind the man
that turned Duke around so they've got
to win tonight they've got a very
competent team UCF with taco false at
seven foot six other really good players
but Johnny Dawkins and his mentor on
Sunday would be pretty cool it just
shows you how the basketball world comes
full circle Fran always great to catch
up whether you have fun and hopefully
we'll talk again soon sounds good a damn
appreciate that's a friend for Shilov
the mothership working for Westwood One
as one of their studio analyst for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]